in the same way you might take a
Christmas tree and stick it in dough and
have perfect edges the cookie cutter
shark is able to do this with its teeth
a cookie cutter shark is sometimes known
as a cigar shark because of the shape of
its body there are deep water species
and they're really creepy looking they
have large eyes funny shaped snouts and
a mouth with triangulated teeth on the
bottom and erect teeth on the top
[Music]
and while it has an adorable name it's
capable of cutting perfectly cylindrical
plugs of flesh out of its victims cookie
cutter sharks spend the majority of
their time at depths below 1,000 meters
so below 3,200 feet on the sea there are
extremely deep water sharks but the
interesting thing is that they come up
at night hunt they are successful in
feeding at nighttime because they have
photophores which emit bioluminescent
light which mimics smaller fish and so
animals like dolphins whales Marlin and
tuna think that these glowing lights on
the cookie cutter shark are actually
prey and when they come in to bite
thinking that it's a smaller fish they
find themselves in a world of hurt
because the cookie cutter shark then
turns around
suctions its lips and its top teeth to
their body and then it spins its body
ejecting a perfectly cylindrical plug of
flesh the cookie cutter sharp is the
only parasitic shark in the entire
Animal Kingdom they are quite small the
male's only get up to about 16 inches
with females to about 22 inches and so
when they are attacking their prey they
really only take plugs in the way that a
parasite would do
and it's quite a characteristic plug
shape and in fact they've even found
some of these plugs on the on the heads
of nuclear submarines humans don't
encounter them very often because during
the daytime they're generally
significantly deeper than human activity
so unless you're in the deep ocean in
the middle of the night it's probably
safe to say you won't be attacked by a
cookie-cutter shark
[Music]
[Music]